Tim Roth's son core mcroth has died he
was 25 years old remember that life is
short and uh
you don't always get to choose your
destiny and you don't always get to
choose
your
you know
your future but just
be an undeniable force that
lives and breathes that thing that you
claim that you love and that you are
and really do it the Pulp Fiction star
shared the news in a statement telling
E.T his son died October 16th following
a courageous battle with cancer quote he
died peacefully in the arms of his
family who loved and adored him he
fought with Incredible bravery for the
past year and maintained his Wicked wit
and humor to the very end Tim went on to
share that from a young age his son had
a love for the Arts explaining that he
was an exceptionally gifted and
extraordinary musician whose passion and
love for making music stretched back to
when his guitar was bigger than he was
quote he was a wild and electric ball of
energy and his Spirit was filled with
light and goodness as wild as he was
cormic was also the embodiment of
kindness a gentle soul who brought so
much happiness and hope to those around
him
back in July cormic posted this clip
revealing he was diagnosed with stage 3
germ cell cancer writing that he was
fighting it daily but it hadn't taken
away his will to survive or love of
making music
and in the wake of his death Tim says
the grief comes in waves as do the tears
and laughter quote we love him we will
carry him with us wherever we go Tim
ended his statement with some wisdom
from his late son quote in cormic's
words make sure you do the things you
love
If It Makes You Happy really do it
and uh that's all I got and I love you